afternoon oh my it's the morning because
I woke up in the past two three hours
therefore it is still the morning did
you order your PDA with you I brought my
Pedialyte with me because I do need to
finish it
come have a sip I can't reach so I don't
sure it's even here I can't reach for
sure for sure confirm that can't reach
okay well where do I want to try you
guys welcome to the special edition
morning toast after the afternoon toast
sorry the the the late the late morning
to late morning toast we are dead we had
my birthday party last night and it was
wonderful but we made the very
responsible decision to push the toast
back a couple hours so that's just in
case we weren't feeling great we were
still able to do the show because we're
four for four this week and we're about
to make it a home run a grand slam not
only is it a full 5-day week the two of
us it's been premium episodes like I
can't even decide which has been the
best episode of the week like I want to
say Monday I want to say Wednesday with
Raven because like I was tying my
friends last night because obviously
they didn't watch the toast so rude you
need to present what we're even told us
that her and Nick never consummated the
relationship and they were so short they
were like ABC went to all of those
lengths to show that like Nick gave her
her first orgasm and it's all the lies
the lies and totally eyes no one talking
about the lies well live in style picked
it up as did Inquisitor so we're in the
news we are we're making news found it
all so I have to tell you guys about
something I just that just happened to
me which was essentially I just saw a
oscar-nominated film because it's true I
just saw funny cuz it's true I just saw
the best movie I've ever seen in my
entire life what's it called an original
film by Jackie O well you know what so
now I'm really taking this director of
patreon very seriously this role and
we've started doing these videos that
are behind the scenes we did the behind
the scenes of the toast that people
really liked and I feel like it's a
whole feature it's so much more elevated
than a podcast right it's so much more
elevated podcast but is this is like a
miniseries that word that we're working
with and I and I've come up with a name
for it tell me behind the scenes
ah that's so good I'm the scenes we
filmed an episode last night at
Claudia's birthday party and I just saw
Jackie like literally I had nothing to
do with that Jackie do the whole thing
all night at her party I was bothering
everyone filming them like little
vignettes it felt like I was doing a Bar
Mitzvah video like asking everyone to
like talk about yeah but the thing is
why it's so epic it's like when you
drink and like you have a night out you
don't really remember like little things
and then like you always say like I wish
we film the night and we could've see
everything and that's literally what we
did right that's like the best part of
having a reality show I would think it's
like you have all these memories like
home movies yep so now we're making our
own grassroots reality show on patreon
and you should totally be a part of it
the video will be up later today
it is pretty hell so funny it's so fun I
just couldn't stop laughing it's cringy
it's funny it's heartwarming it's just
so good and it's raw because yeah we
don't have the skills editing skills to
make it smooth yeah so I hope you guys
all enjoyed that that'll be coming out
this afternoon for your weekend viewing
pleasure watch it on the big screen
patreon.com/scishow morning toast some
other housekeeping announcements my
Boston show sold out which like I'm dead
because I had the biggest pet about it I
know and like it literally sold out
before it even went on sale because
maybe now the patreon pre sailors like
definitely sent the link to like their
friends and the link got out like I
wasn't gonna stop it right so don't buy
tickets to my show yeah I'm being really
pressured to do a second show but like I
kind of just want to take this as a huge
win and bounce but I'm thinking about a
second show I'm thinking about it I feel
like I'm a debacle always like are a lot
of people being like at a show
so I'm just looking at the comments
right now people are like I'm devastated
but like I don't know I'm and this
happens to me all the time like a [ __ ]
like why can't I just take the success
and just I think that you should like be
done with the pits be done with the
anxiety you're sold out Comique and like
an actual reputable theater I'm on a
billboard right and you gotta leave a
money more I kind of agree I can't
believe I'm your billboard that's the
most impressive not a big Missouri I
think that's like them even if it wasn't
having Missouri which it isn't it's on
the highway and it's legit as hell I
think that's like the biggest deal ever
I didn't know it's like what benchmark
until I saw I mean either
and I nobody told me about it that's
what's so crazy this is the second time
I was also one in Chicago but it was
like a little one this is like on a
highway like legit but no one tells you
about it like I guess when you like do
these deals I don't know because I don't
book the shows like there's like a whole
thing where it's like they are they have
to a lot like X amount of money to
promote the show and I guess a billboard
is a way to do that it is it's not crazy
you are billboard dad what's that
mary-kate and Ashley a little more dad I
don't remember what an ad on a billboard
for their dad to get a date they maybe
you'll remember them painting the
billboard that sounds for Mary but I do
dementia so right and you did say
thinking about the airplane in Iceland
you talked about your memories I'm gonna
like I just need the justification like
I know that I said verse that it I can
admit like last night you told me a
story and you were like you haven't
heard this story and then you told me
and I'm like it sounds familiar I like
no it's not that you would admit it if
you remembered it but it's like you're
ashamed for some reason to go 7 that I
didn't say there's nothing funny about
it I was just going to say it's a very
shameful thing to say no it's not
it is cool you walk onto a plane in cold
New York you step off in honky-tonk
central that's cool yeah honky tonk
central by the way my shirt is Kanye how
cool am I you're so cool that's a really
cool shirt no I couldn't believe that
like I did something cool do you know
anything like I just happened to be on
Twitter the moment he released the merch
and I'm like sure people are gonna want
it so like I'll get a tea you'll get it
and sell it
no no I'm loving it no but if you didn't
love it you could sell it totally really
turn a profit pretty penny do we have
well-rounded stories today are back to
our usual hello I I can't go back to the
usually there's so many people we've
gotten such positive feedback on the
caliber of stories that we're reporting
on and like people are so happy we're
not talking about Megan Marco every day
no but not only that it's like I feel
like we're really making an impact in
the lives of young Millennials and I
have information for you guys that's
gonna like impact how do your life now I
can't think about straws like without a
pit oh my god I took a picture with this
jar last night and I was like am I being
controversial no it's like like oh man I
was just gonna say something so
controversial I won't say but like
drinking with a straw it's like the new
like what's a terrible thing people do I
mean there are a lot of them I know and
like I just can't say you can't
because I can say I guess this one like
taking a picture with a straw or like
having a straw on your drink is the new
like dressing up as a Nazi for Halloween
Harry Harry Hamlin from sorry yeah
that's crazy hurry home Luna I think I
got the photo in like right before it's
really about to explode but I felt weird
and I was like do I draw attention to
the straw in the caption or okay
everybody wearing I mean taking a
picture with a straw in your drink it is
like wearing real fur yes or but in a
photo you can lie in say Arthur's fake
right taking a picture with a straw
it's like having a dog from a puppy
store it's like really frowned upon it's
not illegal it's just like a puppy now
pup no publisher Oh like you're not
supposed to get a dog from well you're
only supposed to like rescue dogs no no
here's what it is it's you're a great
person if you rescue a dog and like
everyone should you're like a bad person
who doesn't care about animals and you
get it from a pet store and you're just
right in the middle if you get it from a
breeder there's nothing unethical about
a breeder it's just like you you're
taking a dog into your home you should
take one who needs a home
right but like the dogs in the store I I
understand what you're saying cuz it
creates this cycle and no one bought
store-bought dogs anymore they would
stop like breeding them in cages but
like you see a puppy in the one right
you're technically rescuing it is that
doggy in the window that's true -
absolutely that's a great point so it's
a real Sophie's Choice dogs are like
over bred right I don't know I don't
know I don't know a lot about breeding
I'm gonna be honest let shocks me that
you don't know okay
are you ready for the fast eye story set
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast I
hope I know that you've eaten something
because it is late but not too much cuz
it's only 12:30 wait I got sent k'kaw
fragrance yesterday I saw had its
packaging okay the packaging was amazing
it's a peach fragrance so she put it the
bottle itself is like the big peach
emoji with like frosting coming down and
she put it in a box filled with peach
gummies that Ben is obsessed with like
he ate literally all of them and let me
tell you the bottle was so cute and I
gave her spritz and when I first smelled
it smelled like duty and no like actual
duty but it was like it was the first
spritz of the first bottle but then as
it settled it smells
amazing it smells like pink sugar like
the the fragrance we used to wear
growing up but like peach flavored it
smells like a heaven like I actually
could see Kim smelling like that okay
but for some reason when I first did it
like some maybe was something in my nose
but I smell do do farted I don't know
actually Theo was right below me okay
Jackie was the craziest thing ever you
ever just like smell duty like when we
went to Chipotle and we smelled Duty we
tasted Duty did you ever taste to the a
Chipotle we went once it smell that we
tasted duty we've never been back so
imagine those people who are like
Chipotle's life yeah there you do TV
every day coli they're grabbing a spoon
I don't know maybe something in my nose
or like something in the atmosphere but
it smelled so bad and I was like no
there must I must have gotten the wrong
bottle and then as it said old Frank it
smells so good okay really good okay and
what about the cherry one that was the
one that looks most interesting to me I
know I was like wondering why I got the
peach remember how she sent out everyone
different colored boxes I thought it was
like a tree oh no so now I wonder like
what the peach means right maybe now she
wants you to buy it because I she's
enticed you know
yeah she's enticing you okay ready for
your first story wait here are the first
five stories that you need to know
before you wait before you before you
head to lunch with Sally and eat tickle
time afternoon toast yeah
pervert 2018 Emmy nominations this
year's biggest snubs and surprises lots
of The Handmaid's town Saturday Night
Live and a surprising lack of Will and
Grace
that's not surprised not surprised
affair the television Academy is still a
mostly predictable beast but as ever in
the nominations for the 70th Emmy Awards
still manage to surprise us the biggest
shock is at an HBO film performance
tailor-made to appeal to awards voters
somehow ended up being overlooked
Al Pacino's starring role in paterno the
industry has a noted weakness for star
power and Pacino in particular so rarely
does projects for the small screen that
has lead role as the disgraced football
coach Joe Paterno was thought to be a
shoe-in for sure that sounds really good
yeah never heard never heard of it but
voters apparently were not impressed the
movie was at least nominated for
Outstanding TV movie which is more than
we can say for the other big snub in the
hybrid limited series movie in special
categories David Lynch is a teen part
twin peaks' the return oh I did hear
that was good though
my name is for nine awards including
writing and directing for Lynch himself
star Kyle MacLachlan aka Trey aks Orson
he's it's such a long career he has and
he's an amazing actor I couldn't agree
more and he's the nicest guy you know
him I met him once like when I was
interning somewhere and he was a gem and
I was running the social media and like
he was tweeting I mean we were like
tweeting each other back where was this
at my old job cool uh the company that
shall not be named Oh got it I'm dead
for that category the Academy honoured
pop legend John Legend for his lead role
in Emmy C's fantastic production of
Jesus Christ Superstar my beans he got
if he wins this he's an eagle as the god
he just needs to eat and that's crazy
and I'm no fan of John Legend but I why
I just don't like him what I just like I
just don't like him why he just doesn't
do it for me oh my god first of all he
puts up with Chrissy Teigen so he
deserves that any just that put Chrissy
Teigen like in Our Lives no no I love
John Legend first while he thought sure
he's an amazing voice sure and his music
so good I his music is really good I
just don't like care for him why I don't
know I just like he's like being sunken
by the Chrissy Teigan ship no I agree
with that but taking the Chrissy Teigan
equation out of it very talented man and
I really hope that he wins this one I
love the idea of a guy and the fact that
like nobody is able to achieve it and a
contemporary you got I feel like this
would be the first person that like we
have heard of no and that's like a
celebrity so I'm really excited about it
and that if he gets and he got I will I
would like him okay well you have a high
bar you like people to II got totally um
who else is Antigua I believe Whoopi
Goldberg isn't he got Elton John is he
got is he a Lady Gaga's on her way Lady
Gaga's on her way bit like there what
she could have been he got last year for
American Horror Story and she didn't win
the Oscar oh and also she was nominated
for the song for the song and she got
snubbed and that they gave it to Sam
Smith for that terrible song it should
have been it should have been her and
she wrote it with Diane Warren who has a
weird story line and Kimmy Schmidt
and speaking of Kimmy Schmidt Titus
Burgess so was nominated he gets
nominated every year and always loses
and by the way it's the most deserved
nomination that show it's a sinking ship
and the only thing keeping it alive is
two
Ramadhan and the way he like goes into
character is [ __ ] incredible and he
put the funniest video on his Instagram
because he gets nominated every year and
has never won it he's like it's like
it's not about the wind
it's just about the nomination year
after year after year it's so funny
Instagram is so bad like literally the
opposite of premium content but he put
up a good video that's hilarious
I love him and I just the Emmys don't do
it for me either not surprisingly enough
and - but everyone's like really jazzed
about them like the queer eye guys got
nominated and they're like shook to the
core which I mean if we don't have any
that I would die totally but but what's
so crazy and by the way I didn't realize
Jonathan Ben asks jvn was nominated for
queer eye but he also got nominated for
gay of Thrones which is a webseries I
saw a couple years ago and thought it
was so funny and it always knew Jonathan
Van Ness looked familiar and he's the
guy from Game of Thrones it looks
nominated for four girls which is very
exciting what is it is it um Comedy
Central about your dad where does
anything that's amazing that is Emmys
being into Miss what's necessary totally
I don't even know you could get not even
queer I like I didn't know you could
nominated for a reality show
we're like a web show so technically
could this be nominated for an Emmy
nobody could be nominated for a
straining and I got an email from the
people at streamys like to nominate
ourselves and I fell into that trap once
until you it's a paid and weight you
have to pay to nominate yourself ready
and you do it per category so they said
I was so honored when I got the email
and I realized like everyone and their
mothers get the email so they can make
money and I was just an [ __ ] who fell
in the trap and they're like we suggest
you be in humor and then I saw a bunch
of categories that I fit into and you
could check more than one so I checked
all the categories and checked out and I
didn't realize that you have to pay for
every category
I accidentally changed $2,000 I was on
the phone with the bank I was so pissed
like what electric it's a Ponzi scheme
the streamys oh my it's a Ponzi scheme
so I got the same email this year did
not answer that's crazy but we should
win the streaming we should be the
Streamy and also on what are the stream
what are the other digit webbie's well
shorty shorty i have a shortage and
we're so short like we're so short
yeah I have a shorty that's goals
Shorty's like a melody there should be
like an e got but like for like shorties
streaming Oh God yeah it's called
sadness
it's called get a real job okay the
whole article is really long Congrats to
the women of Saturday Night Live a fan
favorite Congrats a handmade towel
Congrats to Game of Thrones which is the
number one nominated of course but they
get it in like the real talented like
category it's like set design costume
design scripture you know you get like
the real award it's not like Supporting
Actress no to actually do have
supporting actress Lena Headey Cersei
she's good yeah she's great
there's like I really [ __ ] hate her
and she's doing a good job no I know
well I'm so excited for game with those
come back I know is it ever coming again
we'll talk about Game of Thrones on the
show and like that's always premiums
hell no totally and honestly our Game of
Thrones recaps are like some of the best
I don't say that about everything we do
like if sometimes are Beverly Hills and
we lost sighs steps are very basic yeah
but our name of Thrones recaps are so
epic like it's [ __ ] because there's
so much like a funny [ __ ] that goes on
it's just great we were mental in that
era Yura oh my god I wouldn't I would be
a queen speaking of era we think he news
has heard our cries oh my god you guys
did you see what they posted this
morning a picture of Taylor Swift Gigi
Hadid the caption said a toast to my
real friends they don't care about the
he-said she-said which is a social earth
so it said a toast and before the
beginning of the caption was the toast
emojis the clinking glasses which is our
yeah and they never put emojis in their
captions let alone at the beginning so I
think it was like someone there saying
we we see you seeing us see you know
they're talking to us in Morse code like
this Morse code and we dnews we hear it
we see it we appreciate it
keep sending us messages though because
that will be over the fact that you're
stealing all of our content like if you
keep like you can Joel G Goss and if you
keep giving you a small message is that
like we're not crazy and yeah like
exactly art you do watch the toast and
that's fine right we are here I just I
believe off I can't tell if I'm being
like self-centered undramatic thinking
that I make everything up or if he news
is like hardcore stealing there's them
validating my feelings but this emoji is
really nice
no and it's it's not just an emoji like
it's it's a comp it's confirmation I
love to comment on that post with the
toast emojis bread and glasses from the
I chose Instagram feel free to go like
it and maybe they'll respond to us
perhaps anyways we see you thank you and
sometimes we are paranoid about people
stealing from us but I think we keep
ourselves in check yeah we try to like
we don't we know we didn't invent
everything but we had to do a lot we
know the things that we get in men so
Canton shent went okay next up your
favorite girl the wife of Miranda
Lambert's married boyfriend says he
ghosted me
I can't even with Miranda Lambert she is
so trashy she's with a married man who
just like ghosted his wife and like I
don't know I have such a problem with
Miranda Lambert and I can't come enjoy
because for some reason she's like a
trigger for people whenever I talk about
we never I get so much [ __ ] it's like
you think she was like Barack Obama
right but it's because you didn't grow
up like on a dirt road right that's what
a girl said to me she was like you don't
know what it's like to live on a dirt
road I'm like I went to camp okay oh my
goodness I'm not gonna read the story
because like I'm ready bored by it and I
saw a better link on page six
wait Miranda Lambert like cannot go get
good press if she tried who was her
publicist she must be fine but I just
feel like she's just always not in a
good way and her publicist I can't do
anything all she can do was I put out
the music win every single award and go
home and congressional checks yeah yeah
but like all we ever hear about is that
like she's obsessed with Blake their
tumultuous relationship her cheating on
him her breaking up a marriage her
having a 25 year old boyfriend and then
her speaking ill of Garth Brooks
lip-syncing at the CMA Awards last year
right like she needs some some good news
for herself does she have an Instagram I
don't know anyone there thirsting you
know like changing the narrative yeah
getting on comments by celebs totally
that's you can really change things for
yourself okay this next story that I'm
putting in place and Rand Lambert it's
Tom Tom is finally happening do you see
on Instagram yep the latest Vanderpump
rules creation is finally coming to life
Tom Tom restaurant is almost open for
business after almost two years after
Lisa Vanderpump approached Tom Schwartz
in Sanibel with the business venture at
Schwartz his August 2016 wedding - Katie
Maloney that was two years ago yeah yes
but I guess we watched it in 2017 yeah
Sandoval and Schwartz later invested
fifty thousand dollars each for a 5%
stake in the restaurant capture during a
season six episode of terrible deals
terrible deal the restaurant had its
opening on Wednesday night and insider
told page six on Thursday the official
opening is in about three weeks also
what was weird I saw on Instagram and
maybe his fake news but that they did
their soft opening like on Jax's
birthday okay so their soft opening was
July 11th
it was the Daily Mail TV party that they
have every year that was the storyline
of Erika pant Erika's panties and we
were invited but we couldn't go cuz in
LA and they had at that time town huh
that's pretty cool no I knew it's gonna
be a Tom Tom like a couple months ago
thrown I tell you that yeah the opening
was to Daily Mail TV party which is so
smart of them it's a great fusion yes
but was it Jax's birthday that's what
some on Instagram said when's Jax's
birthday you guys July 11th question
mark I don't know that seems too close
to my be like rude like because he's
like not included was he okay
the him then like not including him in
the bars like so bucked up and you know
was intentional like Lisa's part she
hates Jax
squeeze him out yeah and he's like just
such a bit like a bigger person she just
like move on yeah but like if she wanted
to come up with a name with Tom Tom
Jack's like she could have done it like
you know totally do you think it's gonna
be a success I think all of her
restaurants are successes just because
of the show and the people but that cup
runneth over and I think at some point
it's not gonna be like as big of a hit
that's why you could see they're getting
desperate with like all these nights
like see you next Tuesday's summer party
girls night in like they used to just
get people to come to the restaurant
because in the hopes of like seeing
someone waitress but now all of them
like spend literally five minutes a week
at the restaurant and people are like
they don't go anymore cuz they know
they're not gonna see them but now they
know if they go on Tuesday night for
girls on in that all the girls are gonna
be there and so I think they're getting
a little desperate that's all I'm saying
I'm I feel like this season of
Vanderpump brunch with Billy like
definitely think's right will be very
telling like are they evolving or are
they not because last season just hidden
Sean Jackson Britney and him cheating on
her and like that does not a show me for
me no not at all you know but like it's
just the type of show where like even
when it's bad I still enjoy it same with
New York like even when Real Housewives
of New York is bad I still really enjoy
it because I just like the ladies but
like when Beverly Hills is bad I'm like
this sucks yeah it's like so boring but
an OC is bad it's bad I think it's gonna
be really good it has to be or else
they're gonna get can
yeah they know they work overtime Tamara
is not letting that show go down No
Tamara's entire life is predicated on
the success of that show she counts on
those paychecks yeah she really cut
Fitness is not cutting it no but she
does well like on Instagram because of
the show right totally okay next up
Justin Bieber's jeweler reveals how his
beautiful engagement ring for hailey
Baldwin came to be the story is like a
little weird before it was time for
Justin Bieber to pop the question to
hailey Baldwin he needed a diamond to
put on her finger
his manager Scooter Braun knew just who
to call Braun suggested jack solo of
solo & Co Inc diamond jewelers and
Bieber's journey to an engagement ring
for his future bride began having
personally met in spent time with the
popstar years ago Sola was ready to
deliver a diamond perfectly fit for his
famous new client quote I was very
genuinely excited for him and I heard
that he was with somebody very very
special and that they had bonded over
personal things and I was just very very
happy like I would be for any young man
who's on that next stop of his life but
for Justin of course it's that much more
special and that much more visible for
everybody solo explained to E News
exclusively mm-hmm a solo recalled for
enews the star had some ideas for how he
wanted the ring to look Justin had a big
hand in it he had certain design
elements that he wanted and he had
certain expectations and I think we
delivered for example he wanted the
focus to be on the diamond it was all
about the diamond I think he knew very
well what Haley wanted in a ring but he
wanted to be very much about a very
special diamond he left it in my hands
and to select the most beautiful diamond
for someone like Haley that's K I sent
one point he told him to look into there
was one real man when he looked into the
diamond I said what do you see in the
diamond he goes hey I think I see
Haley's face so that was kind of cute
that's one of the lamest things of all
time and I'm starting to hate them no
wow yes had you in an exclusive
interview with a random jeweler in New
York but they probably doesn't even have
an office the really is it's beautiful
it's beautiful I just like I'm over them
do you know what I mean like I'm not
over Peyton Ariana did you see that
video of ariana grande Elle magazine
being so in tune with what's necessary
playing songs association with her no
they did like a bunch of rounds and they
threw a word I turned she had ten
seconds to come up with a song that has
the word in it and like sometimes it was
like they gave her dangerous which was
like obviously her song but like so
funny they did heart and she was like
this is so random but she's saying pop
goes nut
cuz Johnson yeah okay it's the funny but
she was singing like real singing she
sounded amazing and she looked so pretty
and I just feel like you never get to a
like just look at her face like for a
long period of time and to like really
hear her voice like she was singing
amazing that's amazing I have to check
it and then I was just thinking like
though could never do this like they're
so unoriginal like what whoever's idea
it was a tell to do that video is like
really creative and really smart and
really good at their job congratulations
must be nice must be nice anyways yeah
tabeling Justin and Haley for the time
being until they do something
interesting or get a divorce or breakup
yeah did you see the thread in the
morning toasters private Facebook group
by the way the meme you posted on our
Instagram yesterday private Facebook
groups is so funny and so true and I
just like couldn't stop laughing but
there's a thread apparently empty our
boyfriend did an interview he looked as
very random interviews not with like big
publications but like this one random
radio station and the toast and he
basically said that Justin Bieber and
Haley Baldwin are together because he'd
fit Phil's and shiipa feels like a
certain fetish of his which he didn't
say he just said it starts with a P and
ends with a G and then obviously the
toasters figured it out and it's called
pegging okay and I'm just gonna stop
that isn't that a storyline from Real
Housewives one of them like some there
was a pegging party maybe I don't know I
have to rewatch the episode maybe Justin
Bieber was there no and then and he went
on to say that Rihanna has to had sex
with Justin Bieber because they both
like that thing pegging okay yeah I
actually was like embarrassed go to
urban dictionary cuz I didn't want it in
my search history but thank God one of
the girls put a screenshot in I don't
have to do it the toaster up to the
rescue that's hilarious okay next up CNN
money prices are rising faster than they
have in six years if you feel like stuff
has been getting more expensive lately
you're right
honestly I do the Consumer Price Index
which tracks most items on the average
city-dwelling American shopping list
rose 2.9 percent last month its fastest
pace since 2012 when price speed up
paychecks don't go as far a ver egde
hourly earnings only increased 2.7
percent over the year in June which
means that most workers paychecks
actually aren't going any further at all
that sucks ass like things are getting
more expensive
but we don't have more money right like
everything has always been expensive to
meet you know what I mean yeah but like
they're they don't feel particularly
expensive now there was a time where a
piece of pizza was a nickel okay well no
I'm saying but I could get a pop and a
pizza and a night at the movies for 25
cents a pop what are you no no totally
and and I hear you I hear now a pop and
a pizza and a night at the movies cost
you $20 oh my god
way more a movie ticket is 15 like with
tax and stuff but you can get a dollar
slice in the city but where's the pop
from is it from the movie theater
because then you're out like 30 bucks
right no so that isn't it so crazy
no what's so crazy is like there's a
99-cent pizza place like around where we
live and it's amazing it's amazing and
it's just as good it's like a five
dollar slice I know except one time
always I say it's any sense when I went
in there at night like and it smelled
like today and it smelled like throw-up
yeah some girl probably had thrown up
right and I just now associate with
throw up and you know what I've never
looked better but the way Theo is here
today he has his own cam of course and
she's chewing on something and I know
it's something he's gonna be chewing on
but like he's finally quiet and he's a
happy boy and I'm just gonna let him die
on whatever he's gonna choke on
eventually still be live and maybe we'll
get good numbers
do you have movie pasts no but why is it
always in the news I'm always getting a
communication it's about movie paths so
it's a really good idea but I have one
problem with it which is why I have not
done it you pay like I don't know X
amount um per month and then actually
I'm sorry I have no idea what the what
the structure is
I love $10 a month for how many tickets
Oh $10 a month for unlimited tickets but
my problem with it is like you can only
use it on yourself so the [ __ ] who
Scooby's by themselves II took a header
file by yourself is underrated I did it
once in my life and I should do it more
you know like if I want to see a movie
I'm just gonna take my ass to go see it
when I was in high school I saw that
Reese Witherspoon movie called like you
and me or whatever meet you again that's
nice that alone Mitch isn't in it it was
out like Betty White she was in a
fortune no I saw her you so there's food
movie and I went by my Christian
actually yeah I swear I did I got in so
much trouble mom was like are you not so
I was like a kid who like what like
literally a 15 year old on the movies by
herself
it was the weirdest thing ever oh so
much trouble did you get in trouble no
because I was a freshman in college I
remember I came home you guys were on a
trip and you were coming home a few
hours after me so I had a few hours by
myself and in the big city I was like
you know what I'm gonna go see a movie
and I did that's one of the weirdest
things ever now I really want to see a
movie like today we should go yeah but
this movie has included I pick because
the game has changed let's go to I pick
tonight I'm leaving going DTS by the way
I'm not sure or any toaster is gonna be
in Atlantic City this weekend because
I'm I have an opportunity to go tomorrow
and like I really want to go but like is
it lit it's turning around the economy
has been boosted you know prices are
rising
CNN hurricane sandy took Atlantic City
down and like for the like the year
following Atlantic City it was like
every Hotel closed and the Trump Hotel
was the one with like the huge pier and
like the carnival and once that went out
like the whole place me once rebel went
out it was we stopped going cuz we did
it until I for that revel the like day
before it closed lid it's how kazoos
only place with an outdoor pool outdoor
pool right because it's like never hot
in New Jersey so then like it was
literally a ghost town where the only
standing hotel was Borgata I don't know
how they stayed in business but like we
went a couple times it's like super sad
but you never leave the hotel there's
literally a McDonald's in the hotel
there's the casino there's a club early
into the hotel but now that sports
gambling is legal in Atlantic City the
economy is like crazy and revel opened
back up it's called oceans there's a
Hard Rock now there's a million hotels
opening like I'm so happy we're getting
Atlantic City bounties you support the
economy you need to go to Atlantic City
I'll be down the shore 20 minutes away
I'm gonna meet you it's gonna be late as
how is it only 20 minutes way yeah
member that to make that up oh no you
weren't there no one time when we went
to Atlantic City Rebecca was had her
house had sure which is where I'm going
and she came in met us and like she was
five minutes away
oh that's in yeah so what do you guys
have plans I just going to beach yeah we
were just gonna go to beach so you go to
Karma oh my god I don't know go to jail
what a seaside go to jinx I'm not going
to seaside I'm like going like closer to
to me to fill
oh yeah I'm afraid she's from Philly
right okay but it's not Philly I don't
know anyways when the last time I drove
down to her house we passed that city
along the way and that's when anything I
was close
got it okay well I'm really considering
going this weekend it's just like a
last-minute thing like this my last
weekend home till September which is so
annoying I'm grateful for the work I
have to say that every time I complain
about like work I think of like the time
where I had no work and I'm like wow I'm
so grateful to be so tired you know I
mean you really have to think that way
no totally um but so I'm thinking about
it I just want to go it's gonna be like
toasty as hell it will be because all my
friends will be there all the students
who are in America snitches Eames so
done I'm honestly [ __ ] done with her
do you what she did yesterday out of cun
schooi announced on the show yesterday
that Marga was gonna be our intern
starting August 1st I thought me like
I'll discuss it and she was like lucky
to be working for us a million girls
would kill for that job
totally then I see she's responding to
toasters who are like can we pursue me
an intern she's like that's not true
she's responding to comments that's not
true I was like what is she talking
about i watch her story she does a story
saying we had an understanding
saying that these [ __ ] I'm not I'm
not interning for the toast I'm taking
the month of August off so he'd she
texted us she's like I'm not working for
you we're like oh I thought you said
that you were like what you say [ __ ]
choose me so [ __ ] does we're like
we're doing you a favor
and we're like okay you know what don't
work for us go get a real job where you
have to work more than two hours a day
she was like oh my god I just lost my
balance she's like I'm sorry I'm so
sorry can I please work yeah yeah we're
like what you think you're just gonna
come home in for a month and not doing
anything like who do you think you are
she's like no I mean it's whatever I
want right Theo deal you have a little
pink on your nose what is that I'm a
angel baby I promised I wouldn't get
distracted but look here I am getting
distracted by maybe me yeah maybe be
what well for him it's really difficult
not having a credit card or opposable
thumbs so this news doesn't really
affect him right but I'm sure for his
mother it's gonna be hard buying kibble
he is not pulling his weight like when I
got this dog everyone was like he's
gonna he's so expensive he takes so much
like like a constant like meaning and
caring for and like it's fine like he's
gonna be Instagram famous and start
pulling his own weight with the branded
deals
literally he has not brought in one
[ __ ] dollar and he's literally just
at this point just baggage but I just
can't
believe that he's not a bigger Instagram
star everyone has to follow Theo at pup
with no job and tiffany thornton totally
and charge a better in-law and me
alright
and me too I guess ok alright Ben could
use it to Ben got hacked this morning
what's big soft they put someone posted
the gray ban and it's like it was so
like a real hacking he was freaking out
he doesn't know how it happens that's
crazy I know now I feel like I'm next
just you know you got me do what you got
to do but I really can't believe that
he's not more Instagram famous
especially with the loss of one
beautiful cavalier in the dog world
there's an opening toast oh my god do
you guys know toast Meets World the
cutest cat who just heavily or ever got
the fact use dog well actually I'm not
that dude so I cuz they got divorced and
the mother got custody okay so the
Thatcher's ex-wife's dog and he's so
cute and then he died all of a sudden
but he lived a really like long happy
life his name was toasters toast he'd
like did ads for Karen Walker sunglasses
yes some ways were you done literally
nothing I love you so much you don't you
could literally [ __ ] in my bed every day
and I would love you more than life
itself
Wow cuz that's what true love is
literally we got home last night we were
like wasted and I love when Theo sleeps
with us but like I sleep so bad and Theo
sleeps bed to I don't even think he
likes sleeping with us we like force him
to sleep with us so I'm like I want to
get good sleep I have a show tomorrow
and I'm like then I'm putting him in the
crate Ben started hysterically crying
like he was acting like I was taking
Theo to a death camp you thought I was
taking Theo to Auschwitz like I was like
Crete it's bright next our bed and he do
loves his crate he hates sleeping with
us every time you sleep with us he jumps
out and goes into his own crate Ben is
crying he's like you are always taking
my son away from me I don't even know if
he remembers this I have to tell him
when I add to the show like he was being
so dramatic and I'm like but our baby I
mean he loves kriti he loves his mom and
dad and then Sneetches and Smee just the
first I'm the number one an in this
group you guys join you for a hundred
percent by leaps and bounds now like to
bounce anyway it's also it's by default
but it doesn't matter
no it's by default but even when said
she hits back like I've made such
progress yeah that she can't even it
will take her a while if she is she
tries her hardest
yes okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story that actually might change
your daily life yeah
uber is letting riders pay with venmo
now interesante
I don't know how to please this makes
the ride-sharing company the largest to
accept venmo payments uber riders in the
US can now pay for the rides with venmo
starting today users will see a pay with
venmo option next to one for Apple pay
this could make it easier for anyone who
prefers not to link their financial
information to the ride-sharing company
especially temporary users except I've
never heard of uber getting hacked I've
heard of venmo getting hacked so uber I
had like the biggest hack ever it was
like a big deal uber honestly like you
know I ride or literally I'm right about
Hoover and they have found a million
ways to piss me off in the last few
weeks like it's like someone hacked
their system they've been hacked and
what they're doing the hackers is
they're taking every rider like two
blocks out of their way and said and
putting them in traffic and it's like
where as I would have been home ten
minutes ago if we just took the right
box that had no traffic yeah I don't
know if it's like Google and ways
[ __ ] people it's not Google wants to
like deal agendize ways now that they
bought it chugging I've been this way
forever
basically when you get it I watched the
uber phones like when you get a customer
you start the route and the uber map
gives you directions but most of the
drivers just that you can link out to
ways or Google Maps I would say one in
every 10 drivers actually uses the uber
GPS and the uber GPS is moronic like
they literally like will take you 17
blocks out of the way just like cuz it
you technically can go that way like
it's so stupid and so every time I get
in the cab anywhere I'm like Google Maps
please I just I'm really losing my
patience and I've probably taken
thousands of uber rides in my life and
it might be my last soon if they don't
hear my cries I know Jackie was so
pissed we were we got home we were super
same route home every day from here it's
so easy like the route but then if you
do take one wrong turn you can be in a
lot of traffic no if you take one wrong
turn it takes you a little you take one
wrong turn it takes you a little bit
longer and I have to get out on the
corner and that's actually fine I could
use the half a block walk if you take
the three wrong turns you're go up town
ten blocks and you're sitting in traffic
going the wrong way do you ever get into
nuber and it takes you ten minutes
before you're actually close
your destination and what you started
that is the [ __ ] worse no I know
exactly you're saying we were in this
Jackie was so pissed started out looking
Juno like I said like you were hurting
Hooper's feelings nobody like I feel
like I'm a good enough uber customer
that when I leave they will feel my loss
know for sure I can turn this family if
we leave they will feel the loss yeah
you will rue the day you over the day
honestly we're like I will I will go
hard for you if you just show me a
little bit of respect um but I don't get
the point in using venmo like if you
have your phone right oh you need a
credit card for venmo know so that you
don't have to give her your credit card
information and you can keep it all in
venmo so like for people who are worried
about being hats in [ __ ] you know my
[ __ ] is everywhere there were there have
been six million transactions inside of
venmo in the last year alone that we're
discussing uber so I guess people paying
for Hoover's interesante I don't need it
I never write what my bed Mo's for and I
always make it private I'm not into bed
row being like a social thing no totally
so like your friends get like jealous
that you had dinner without them like
right so me and also like the way that I
think of it most is like I use the same
blow a person is like a lot of my
friends but like he gives me sometimes a
no pay sometimes he like gives me just
kind of rate like because I was putting
my my Instagram like I know when I've
been well he might want my friends know
how much I'm paying in because they're
paying like three times as much they
don't see the amount that you pay if
you're really your payment is public
yeah I just do it everything private oh
wait yeah same I don't know
then no school ID chase QuickPay though
it's the best but not enough people know
about it and you don't need chase to do
it what only one of the people needs
chase well that's a game changer I know
it's called though that Alvin knew
they've been advertising it left and I
cuz I have a TD Bank card also and it's
also so ladies are generous in
mysterious financial way it's been an
absolute pleasure hanging out with you
this has been the morning toast
we are the Millennial morning show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern time so make sure you like us on
Facebook like us on YouTube like us on
Instagram all that [ __ ] and we'll
see you on Monday have an amazing
weekend have an amazing weekend
patreon.com slash morning toasts for our
award-winning film that is coming out
today behind the scenes Claudia's
birthday edition it's really good
you